If you're single and looking for love this Valentine's Day, then chances are you're on some dating apps. Over the past two decades, apps and websites have replaced friends, family members, bars, and churches as the most common ways for people to meet a partner. One study from Stanford University found that in 2022, 55% of all new couples met online. That's up from just under 40% in 2017 and only 22% in 2009. Meanwhile, a 2023 Pew Research Center poll found that 3 in 10 U.S. adults of all ages have spent some time on dating websites or apps. So how has the shift to online dating change the way that people meet and form relationships? How might the algorithms that power dating apps and filter our potential partners?
如果你在情人节这天单身并渴望爱情，那么你很有可能会使用一些约会软件。在过去的二十年里，软件和网站已经取代了朋友、家人、酒吧和教堂，成为人们结识伴侣最常见的方式。斯坦福大学的一项研究发现，2022年，所有新情侣中有55%是在网上认识的。这一比例高于2017年的不到40%以及2009年的仅22%。与此同时，皮尤研究中心2023年的一项民意调查发现，全美各个年龄段中，十分之三的成年人都曾在约会网站或软件上花过时间。那么，转向网络约会如何改变了人们相遇和建立关系的方式？驱动约会软件并筛选潜在伴侣的算法又是如何……
affect who we end up with. Do those algorithms do a good job? And what happens to relationships that start online? Are they more or less likely to work out? If you're on dating apps right now, what can you do to increase your chances of success? What are the biggest mistakes that online daters make? And finally, how might developing technologies
影响我们最终和谁在一起的？这些算法做得好吗？网恋开始的关系会有怎样的结局？它们成功的几率更高还是更低？如果你现在正在使用约会软件，你能做些什么来增加成功的几率？网络约会者犯的最大的错误是什么？最后，诸如……
such as artificial intelligence and virtual reality change dating in the future? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Liesel Shirabi. Dr. Shirabi is an associate professor in the Hugh Down School of Human Communication at Arizona State University, where she directs the Relationships and Technology Lab. Dr. Shurabi's research explores how technology is transatlantician. transforming the ways we meet, date, and fall in love.
人工智能和虚拟现实等新技术将如何在未来改变约会？欢迎收听《心理学说话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是莉瑟尔·希拉比博士。希拉比博士是亚利桑那州立大学休·唐恩人类传播学院的副教授，并在那里领导关系与技术实验室。希拉比博士的研究探讨了技术如何正在改变我们相遇、约会和坠入爱河的方式。
Much of her work centers around online dating sites and mobile dating apps. She's also interested in the future of dating, including the role of artificial intelligence in facilitating relationships and intimate relationships in augmented and virtual reality. Dr. Shirabi's research has been published in numerous academic journals and featured by Wired, NPR, Time magazine, and many other media outlets. Dr. Shirabi, thank you for joining me. So happy to be here. Thanks for having me on. So I just mentioned that there's a study that found that more than half of couples now meet online. How do you think that's changed the way that people get to know each other and enter relationships?
她的许多工作都围绕在线约会网站和移动约会软件展开。她还对约会的未来感兴趣，包括人工智能在促进人际关系中的作用，以及增强现实和虚拟现实中的亲密关系。希拉比博士的研究已发表在众多学术期刊上，并被《连线》杂志、美国国家公共电台、《时代》杂志以及许多其他媒体报道。希拉比博士，谢谢你加入我。很高兴来到这里。谢谢邀请我。我刚才提到有一项研究发现，现在超过一半的情侣是在网上认识的。你认为这如何改变了人们相互了解和进入恋爱关系的方式？
I mean, one thing that it's really done is help to expand the dating pool. So now you're no longer limited just to the people who you might happen to run into going about your day-to-day routine. You have so many more options than you had previously. And it also means that you're not. that instead of meeting somebody in person, striking up a conversation, you're being introduced to a profile, and you're getting to know someone in a very different way in that sense, evaluating them on, you know, different types of attributes because you have this two-dimensional profile that is standing in place of the actual person that you would ultimately end up meeting. Let's talk about how most dating apps are working right now. What's going on behind the scenes when an app is showing you a series of profiles to consider, how is it, quote, unquote, deciding which potential partners to offer you?
我的意思是，它真正做的一件事是帮助扩大了约会池。所以现在你不再仅限于日常生活中碰巧遇到的人。与以前相比，你有了更多的选择。这也意味着你不是……也就是说，你不是亲自遇到某人并展开对话，而是被引入一个个人资料，从某种意义上说，你以一种非常不同的方式了解某人，根据各种不同类型的属性来评估他们，因为这个二维的个人资料取代了你最终会见到的真实的人。让我们谈谈大多数约会软件目前是如何运作的。当软件向你展示一系列可供考虑的个人资料时，幕后发生了什么？它是如何“决定”向你推荐哪些潜在伴侣的？
Well, apps do this in different ways. I mean, more recently, they've started to base this primarily on your behaviors. So they look at the profiles that you're swiping on to try to get a sense of your taste. And they also look at the types of people who are swiping on you to try to get a sense of who might be interested. did in you and who would reciprocate if you were to reach out to them. And so they're looking at patterns of swiping behaviors. And specifically, one way that a lot of apps are doing this today is through something called collaborative filtering, where you're swiping on profiles and they're also looking
嗯，软件有不同的运作方式。我的意思是，最近，它们开始主要根据你的行为来进行推荐。所以它们会查看你右滑的个人资料，以试图了解你的品味。它们还会查看右滑你的人的类型，以试图了解谁可能对你感兴趣，以及如果你联系他们的话谁会做出回应。所以它们在寻找右滑行为的模式。具体来说，现在很多软件都在使用的一种方法叫做协同过滤，你在上面右滑个人资料，同时它们也会查看……
at people who appear to be swiping on the same types of people, so people who seem like they have similar taste to you. And based on their patterns of behavior, they're making determinations about who you. you might be interested in seeing next. And it's kind of similar to how Netflix recommends movies to you, how Amazon recommends products, where they don't have to know a whole lot about you because they know what people like you typically do,
那些似乎也在右滑同类型人群的人，也就是看起来和你品味相似的人。根据他们的行为模式，它们来决定你接下来可能会对谁感兴趣。这有点类似于网飞向你推荐电影的方式，或者亚马逊推荐产品的方式，它们不需要对你有很多了解，因为它们知道像你这样的人通常会做什么，
what their taste typically is, and they're able to use that information to then offer you recommendations. So all that is to say that these days apps don't have to ask who you are and what you want. They can draw these inferences just, based on knowing something about how you behave on the platform. Are these algorithms doing a good job? I mean, how do they compare to, say, a human matchmaker or a friend who says,
他们的品味通常是什么，它们能够利用这些信息来向你提供推荐。所以所有这些都说明，现在软件不需要问你是谁以及你想要什么。它们只需根据对你在平台上行为的一些了解，就能做出这些推断。这些算法做得好吗？我的意思是，与人类媒人或一个说“
hey, I know someone you might like? Yeah. I mean, there isn't a lot of evidence that algorithms are better than humans at trying to decide who you would be interested in. But that being said, there is some evidence that believing that an algorithm might know who you would be compatible with can be really powerful in shaping your behaviors in ways that are likely to lead you to more successful outcomes. So as an example of that, if you're using a dating app where they're doing compatibility matching and they're telling you that the partners that you're
嘿，我认识一个你可能会喜欢的人”的朋友相比，它们表现如何？是的。我的意思是，没有太多证据表明算法在决定你会对谁感兴趣方面比人类更好。话虽如此，确实有一些证据表明，相信算法可能知道谁与你兼容，在塑造你的行为方面可以非常强大，从而更有可能带给你更成功的结局。举个例子，如果你正在使用一个会进行兼容性匹配的约会软件，并且它们告诉你，你正在接触的
being introduced to are really great for you, really perfect, you might behave differently towards those individuals. So you might feel less uncertain about them. You might reveal more about yourself thinking, this person is someone who I'm really going to hit it off with. And because you're engaging in those behaviors, it can make it more likely that you're going to have good outcomes if you were to meet them face-to-face, that your date's going to be more successful because you've already started this process of establishing a very functional relationship. So it's kind of a classic self-fulfilling prophecy. So even if the algorithms aren't necessarily better than we are at knowing who we're going to be compatible with,
伴侣真的非常适合你，非常完美，你可能会对这些人表现得不同。所以你可能会对他们减少不确定性。你可能会透露更多关于你自己的信息，心想，这个人真的是我会一见如故的人。正因为你参与了这些行为，如果你和他们面对面见面，你更有可能获得好的结果，你们的约会会更成功，因为你已经开始了建立一个非常功能性的关系的过程。所以这有点像经典的自我实现预言。因此，即使算法不一定比我们更擅长了解谁与我们兼容，
the way that we perceive them and how we engage with them can play a role in making us successful. And is it only compatibility or is it also looking at geographic location or do you have to specify? Yeah. So if you're using a dating app, a lot of apps are based on geographic locations. So it's showing you people who are nearby. And in doing that, they've made this experience more similar to how we've always gotten to know someone face to face, which is by looking around us, looking around in our communities, and seeing who we might be interested in. So they want to make it really easy for people to strike up a conversation and then quickly get off the app and actually go out there and meet somebody and go on a date. So geographic location plays a role in this, but there are other factors that are playing a role as well, including the types of profiles.
我们对它们的看法以及我们如何与它们互动，都可以在让我们成功方面发挥作用。这只是关于兼容性，还是也着眼于地理位置，或者你必须指定？是的。所以如果你在使用约会软件，很多软件都是基于地理位置的。所以它会向你展示附近的人。通过这样做，它们让这种体验更类似于我们一直以来面对面了解某个人的方式，也就是环顾四周，环顾我们的社区，看看我们可能会对谁感兴趣。因此，它们希望让人们非常容易地展开对话，然后迅速离开软件，真正走出去见某人并去约会。所以地理位置在其中发挥了一定作用，但还有其他因素也在发挥作用，包括你右滑的个人资料类型，
that you're swiping on and the types of people who are showing an interest in you in return. Anyone who's used dating apps will tell you that men's and women's experiences tend to be quite different on these platforms. Why is that and what are the different problems that men and women generally have to deal with, at least in the context of heterosexual dating? Yeah. So on a lot of platforms, there is a gender imbalance where you have more male users and you have fewer female users. And so for people who are looking for heterosexual relationships, this can create some really interesting dynamics.
以及对你表现出兴趣并回馈你的人的类型。任何使用过约会软件的人都会告诉你，男性和女性在这些平台上的体验往往截然不同。为什么会这样，男性和女性通常必须处理哪些不同的问题，至少在异性约会的背景下是这样？是的。所以在很多平台上，存在性别失衡，即男用户较多，女用户较少。因此，对于寻找异性关系的人来说，这会产生一些非常有趣的动态。
And you end up with these situations where men are maybe getting fewer matches when they reach out to people. They're not getting as many responses because women are feeling overwhelmed. They're getting a lot of attention. They have a lot of people competing for their attention on these platforms. And it can be really difficult to keep up with that. And so you create this environment where potentially some people are putting in a lot of work trying to meet somebody, trying to match with people. And then other people are getting so much attention that they're overwhelmed and they're just not able to keep up.
最后你会遇到这样一种情况：男性在联系他人时可能会获得较少的匹配。他们得到的回复没有那么多，因为女性感到不堪重负。她们得到了很多关注。在这些平台上，有很多人在争夺她们的注意力。要跟上这一点可能会非常困难。因此，你创造了这样一个环境：可能有些人付出了很多努力去试图认识某人，试图与人匹配。而另一些人则得到了如此多的关注，以至于他们不知所措，根本无法应付。
And so when you look at men and women, they can end up with these fundamentally different experiences on the platform where for some people, it's really expanding their pool. They really feel like they have a lot of options. And for other people, they feel like they're putting it a lot of. lot of time and effort, but it's not actually leading them anywhere. And this is where algorithms can become helpful in trying to make sure that people are being shown profiles of potential partners who are actually going to reciprocate if they were to reach out and who are actually going to be interested because it's a big problem on dating apps. What's the proportion of men to women on most of these apps? Do you know? I don't know. I mean, it would really depend
因此，当你审视男性和女性时，他们最终会在平台上获得这些截然不同的体验，对某些人来说，这确实扩大了他们的选择池。他们真的觉得有很多选择。而对其他人来说，他们觉得自己投入了大量的时间和精力，但实际上并没有带来任何进展。这就是算法可以发挥作用的地方，它们试图确保人们看到的是那些如果被联系时实际上会做出回应并且实际上会感兴趣的潜在伴侣的个人资料，因为这是约会软件上的一个大问题。大多数软件上男女性别的比例是多少？你知道吗？我不知道。我的意思是，这真的取决于
on the specific platform that somebody is using. And so I don't have any specific numbers in terms of the gender balance, aside from saying that on a lot of them, there does tend to be more male users. But yeah, I don't know. Is that something proprietary that the companies don't want to release? Because if you knew, you might not be playing. Yeah. So much of this is proprietary. I mean, we can make assumptions. We can make inferences based on, you know, people who are using them. but there's only so much we can know without actually having access to some of that proprietary data. What about for people who are looking for same-sex partners, are their experiences different
某人使用的具体平台。因此，除了说在许多平台上男性用户确实往往更多之外，我没有任何关于性别平衡的具体数字。但是的，我不知道。这是公司不想发布的那种专有信息吗？因为如果你知道了，你可能就不会玩了。是的。其中很大一部分是专有的。我的意思是，我们可以做出假设。我们可以根据使用它们的人做出推断，但如果不实际访问其中一些专有数据，我们能知道的就只有这么多了。对于寻找同性伴侣的人来说，他们的体验是否与寻找异性约会的人不同？
from people who are looking for opposite sex dates? Yeah, absolutely. And there are also different types of platforms that cater specifically to people who are looking for same-sex partners. So you have the dating apps like Tinder and Hinge and Bumble that cater to really broad demographic of users. And then you also have these niche dating apps, some of them catering specifically to people who are looking for same-sex relationships.
是的，完全不同。而且也有专门迎合寻找同性伴侣的人的不同类型的平台。所以你有像Tinder、Hinge和Bumble这样迎合广泛用户群体的约会软件。然后你也有这些小众约会软件，其中一些专门迎合寻找同性关系的人。
So I think about Grindr, which was actually a precursor to apps that we have today, like Tinder that caters to men who are looking for other men-form relationships with. You have apps like her. So there are specific platforms that are designed to. to facilitate those types of relationships. You've done some research comparing long-term relationships that started online with those that started some other way. What have you found? Is there any difference in relationship quality or divorce rate or any other factors? So 10 years ago, just about 10 years ago, there was a study that came out that compared the marriages of couples that were meeting online to the marriages of couples who were meeting face-to-face.
所以我想到了Grindr，它实际上是我们今天拥有的像Tinder这样的软件的前身，它迎合了寻找与其他男性建立关系的男性的需求。你还有像Her这样的软件。因此，有专门设计的平台来促进这些类型的关系。你做过一些研究，比较了网恋开始的长期关系与通过其他方式开始的关系。你发现了什么？在关系质量、离婚率或任何其他因素方面有什么区别吗？所以10年前，大约10年前，曾有一项研究将网上认识的夫妇的婚姻与面对面认识的夫妇的婚姻进行了比较。
And what they found was that people who were meeting online were a little bit more satisfied in their relationships. They were a little bit more stable. And so that was a pretty positive outcome. So you would like to think that if you use online dating, maybe that's going to mean that you have a more successful long-term relationship. Not a lot of work has been done in that area since. And so recently, my colleague and I actually collected some data to try to see if those effects, still hold today. So if it is still the case that people who are meeting through online dating are more successful in the long run. And we actually found that the effects were in the opposite
他们发现的是，网上认识的人在他们的关系中稍微更满意一些。他们稍微更稳定一些。所以这是一个相当积极的结果。因此，你会倾向于认为，如果你使用网络约会，也许这意味着你将拥有一个更成功的长期关系。自那以后，该领域没有做太多工作。因此最近，我和我的同事实际上收集了一些数据，试图看看这些影响今天是否仍然存在。所以通过网络约会认识的人从长远来看是否仍然更成功。而我们实际上发现，影响正好相反
direction. So people who are meeting through online dating were actually a little bit less satisfied in their marriages. They were a little bit less stable, more likely to consider divorce. And these aren't big effects by any means. So these aren't big differences. But at the same time they're noteworthy. And so you might start to think, okay, what could explain that? What's changed in the past 10 years? And one of the big changes that's happened is just the shift from online dating sites to mobile dating apps because we're now about a decade into mobile dating. We're starting to see some of the long-term implications of forming relationships this way. And so it's seeming like perhaps that's playing a role in some of the outcomes that people are
方向。所以通过网络约会认识的人在他们的婚姻中实际上稍微不那么满意。他们稍微不那么稳定，更有可能考虑离婚。无论如何，这些都不是很大的影响。所以这些并不是巨大的差异。但与此同时，它们值得注意。所以你可能会开始思考，好吧，什么可以解释这一点？过去10年发生了什么变化？其中一个重大的变化就是从在线约会网站向移动约会软件的转变，因为我们现在大约已经进入移动约会十年了。我们开始看到以这种方式建立关系的一些长期影响。因此，看起来这可能在人们所经历的一些结果中发挥了作用。
experiencing. And so then you can, you know, think even more about what's different about dating apps in particular. But I mean, the matchmaking process is different. The process that people follow to actually initiate a relationship where you're swiping on profiles that are very much centered around photos rather than self descriptions. And then the fact that you're having to go through lots of profiles, you're meeting lots of people. And you just have lots of offers. And you just have lots of offers. And so it's easy to go back to the dating pool if something doesn't work out or if somebody doesn't exactly meet your expectations. What about the probability of a date turning into marriage, assuming that that's the dater's goal? How to online matches compare to other types of matches in that realm?
然后你可以更深入地思考约会软件有什么特别不同的地方。但我的意思是，匹配过程是不同的。人们实际发起关系的过程是不同的，你右滑的个人资料非常集中在照片上而不是自我描述上。然后事实上你必须浏览大量的个人资料，你要见很多人。而且你有很多选择。而且你有很多选择。因此，如果事情没有成功，或者如果某人没有完全达到你的期望，重回约会池是很简单的。假设这是约会者的目标，一次约会变成婚姻的概率是多少？在这方面，网络匹配与其他类型的匹配相比如何？
Yeah. So the big thing to know about online dating is that not everyone is looking for a committed long-term relationship. and I think this is a big source of frustration for a lot of people, especially people who are interested in commitment because it can be really hard to figure out what people's goals are and to find people whose goals align with your own. And I think it also, there's this mindset and this attitude that comes up in online dating where people kind of feel like
是的。所以关于网络约会，需要了解的一件大事是，并不是每个人都在寻找承诺的长期关系。我认为这对许多人来说是一个巨大的挫折之源，特别是对那些对承诺感兴趣的人来说，因为弄清楚人们的目标是什么以及寻找目标与自己一致的人真的很难。而且我认为这也……在网络约会中会出现这样一种心态和态度，即人们有点觉得
because it's so easy to form relationships, because they have so many options available to them, it can almost start to make relationships feel a little bit disposable in the sense that you might find that you're really hitting it off with someone, but in the back of your mind you might wonder, okay, is somebody better out there? If I just keep swiping, is that going to lead me to someone that's even more perfect than the person I'm interacting with right now? And I compare that to the experience of dating before we had these apps where if you meet someone, you're only meeting so many people who, you might be romantically interested in, just going about your day-to-day routine. So you might give them a chance. And even if they're not perfect, you might still sort of put in the work to see if that relationship can go somewhere. But with dating apps, I think that there is this attitude sometimes that it's about finding
因为建立关系太容易了，因为他们有太多的选择，它几乎开始让人觉得关系有点像用完即弃的，你可能会发现你和某人一见如故，但在你的脑海深处你可能会想，好吧，外面会不会有更好的人？如果我一直右滑，会不会带我找到一个比我现在正在互动的人还要完美的人？我将其与我们拥有这些软件之前的约会体验进行对比，如果你遇到某人，你只会遇到那么多可能对你产生浪漫兴趣的人，只需进行你的日常生活。所以你可能会给他们一个机会。即使他们不完美，你可能仍然会付出努力，看看这段关系能否有所发展。但对于约会软件，我认为有时存在这样一种态度，即它是关于寻找
the perfect person as opposed to building a strong relationship with someone despite their flaws. And so you've got people who spend a whole lot of time swiping. and then not, I think, enough time actually trying to build a good relationship with one person that they are committed to. And there's been a lot written about the tendency of younger generations today to pursue perfection in everything. I mean, is that playing a role here? I think that's what I'm hearing you say. Yeah, I mean, I really think it is.
完美的人，而不是尽管有缺点却与某人建立牢固的关系。所以你会发现有些人花大量时间在右滑上，然后我认为没有花足够的时间真正尝试与一个他们承诺的特定人建立良好的关系。关于今天年轻一代在所有事情上追求完美的倾向，已经有很多文章了。我的意思是，这在这里起作用吗？我想这就是我听到你说的。是的，我的意思是，我真的认为是的。
I think that people spend a lot of time. I mean, they go into online dating with this almost wish list. this list of qualities that they're looking for in their perfect partner and they spend a lot of time trying to find it. And you can swipe endlessly in order to do that. And you can find people who are really great. But if your goal is perfection, you're going to spend a lot of time on the apps and probably less time in relationships because no one is perfect. I mean, it's unrealistic to think that that's going to be the outcome of all of this. And so a much, I think, healthier mindset would be finding someone who's interesting to you, someone you're attracted to, who you're willing to put in the work with.
我认为人们花了很多时间。我的意思是，他们带着几乎是一份愿望清单进入网络约会。这份清单列出了他们在寻找完美伴侣时所寻找的品质，他们花了很多时间试图找到它。为了做到这一点，你可以无休止地右滑。你可以找到真的很棒的人。但如果你的目标是完美，你将在软件上花费大量时间，而在关系中花费的时间可能会减少，因为没有人是完美的。我的意思是，认为这就是这一切的结果是不切实际的。因此，我认为更健康的心态是找到一个对你有趣的人，一个你被吸引的人，一个你愿意与之一同付出努力的人。
And I think sometimes with dating apps, people lose sight of that because it's just so easy to meet people now and to evaluate them on qualities that sometimes, you know, don't end up mattering in the long run as much as we might think that they would. Do you have other advice for people who are on apps that might maximize their chances of success? I mean, should you limit the amount of time that you spend or how many swipes after 100 people should you stop? I mean, are there tips that you can offer our listeners? Yeah. I mean, I think that people sometimes experience choice overload where they're swiping so much that they start to get overwhelmed. And you get to this point where all of the profiles and the faces start to blur together. And I think that's when you know that you've reached your stopping point.
而且我认为有时通过约会软件，人们会忽略这一点，因为现在结识人太容易了，并且根据有时最终并不像我们想象的那样重要的品质来评估他们。你对在软件上的人有什么其他建议，可以最大化他们成功的几率吗？我的意思是，你应该限制花费的时间吗？或者在100个人之后你应该停止右滑？我的意思是，有什么小贴士可以提供给我们的听众吗？是的。我的意思是，我认为人们有时会经历选择过载，他们右滑得太多，以至于开始感到不知所措。你会到达这样一个点，所有的个人资料和面孔开始融为一体。我认为这就是你知道自己已经到了停止点的时候。
So it can help to limit how much you're swiping so that you're seriously considering the people in front of you. Instead of just going through them one by one and rolling them out based on things that, again, might not matter so much. I know a lot of people look at things like height. They look at things like what somebody does for living. They look at their hobbies. And it can be really easy to see one thing that you don't like and immediately just swipe left, reject it, move on to the next person. And so I think it helps to really consider that these are, you know, human beings that are much more complex. than what you might be seeing in the profile
所以限制你右滑的次数会有所帮助，这样你就可以认真对待面前的人。而不是仅仅一个接一个地浏览他们，并根据同样可能并不那么重要的因素排除他们。我知道很多人看重身高之类的事情。他们看重某人做什么工作。他们看重他们的爱好。看到一个你不喜欢的东西并立即向左滑动、拒绝、转到下一个人，这真的很容易。因此，我认为记住这些是更复杂的真人会有所帮助，
and to really think through each person as if they were right in front of you as opposed to falling into that swiping mindset. I also think a lot of these problems can be addressed by getting off the app as well. So spending more time actually using it the way it was intended, which is to introduce you to people and then letting the actual relationship development part
而不是你在个人资料中看到的，并像他们就在你面前一样认真考虑每个人，而不是陷入那种右滑的心态。我还认为，通过离开软件，也可以解决许多这类问题。所以花更多时间真正按照它的预期使用它，也就是向你介绍人们，然后让实际的关系发展部分
play out offline as opposed to to spending a lot of time messaging back and forth and then meeting and finding that this person maybe wasn't entirely what you expected. And then you also end up back on the apps and back in the dating pool. Yeah. So speaking of what you expected when you meet somebody, what about safety? What about the question of making sure that the person you're meeting really is what he or she says they are and that if you do meet that you're not going to be stalked by somebody for the next six months? Yeah, I mean, I think you always want to make sure that when you're meeting people from dating apps, that you're doing that in a public location, that you tell someone where you're going, that you're smart about it and that you do try to stay safe because dating apps are designed to introduce you to strangers. That's the whole point is to expand your network to introduce you to people who you might not otherwise come into contact with.
在线下进行，而不是花大量时间来回发消息然后见面，结果发现这个人可能并不完全是你所期望的。然后你最终又回到了软件上和约会池里。是的。说到你见某人时的期望，安全问题呢？如何确保你见面的人确实是他或她所说的那样，并且如果你见面了，你在接下来的六个月里不会被某人跟踪？是的，我的意思是，我认为你总是想确保当你从约会软件见人时，你是在公共场所进行的，你告诉某人你要去哪里，你对此保持聪明，并且你确实试着保持安全，因为约会软件旨在向你介绍陌生人。这正是扩大你的网络、向你介绍你可能不会以其他方式接触到的人的全部意义所在。
And with that does come some safety concerns. I think that also it can help to at least get to know somebody well enough to where you feel comfortable meeting them. So at least exchanging some messages, maybe even going on a video date, getting on a phone call with that person, so that you can try to vet them a little bit more than you might be able to on the app. But at the same time, not waiting so long to where you're following into this pen pal situation of messaging somebody and building up these these big expectations that would be difficult for someone to live up to. Did the pandemic have any impact on people's use of dating apps? Or is it too soon to even say whether we know this?
随之而来的确实是一些安全问题。我认为这也有助于至少对某人有足够的了解，直到你觉得见面很舒服。所以至少交流一些消息，甚至进行视频约会，与那个人通电话，这样你就可以比在软件上更能对他们进行审查。但与此同时，不要等待太久而陷入发消息的笔友情况，并建立起别人很难达到的大高期望。大流行对人们使用约会软件有什么影响吗？或者现在说我们是否知道这一点还为时过早？
During the pandemic, some of the data coming from the platforms themselves shows that there was a big uptick in online dating because people were at home. They weren't able or weren't comfortable going out and meeting people. And so you had people spending more time on the apps. and you also had people trying them out who maybe hadn't used them before. And so in addition to that, something else that we saw happen during the pandemic was that a lot of people started experimenting with video dating because you, you know, didn't want to go out and go on a face-to-face date with somebody.
在大流行期间，来自平台本身的一些数据显示，网络约会出现了大幅上升，因为人们待在家里的时间变多了。他们无法或不舒服外出结识人。因此，人们花在软件上的时间更多了。
And so video offered an alternative and kind of this step in between messaging somebody and actually putting in the time, the effort to go meet them in person. And so video dating, I mean, it's really a throwback to the 80s when video dating services were also kind of popular. Before we had online dating, people were going on video dates, a different kind of video date. But we saw this again. We saw platforms rolling out video dating features during the pandemic. And I thought that was a really positive step, a step in the right direction. Because when you think about safety concerns, like it does.
而且你也有以前可能没有使用过它们的人尝试它们。除此之外，我们在大流行期间看到的另一件事是，许多人开始尝试视频约会，因为你（你知道）不想出去和某人进行面对面的约会。因此，视频提供了一种替代方案，有点介于给某人发消息和实际投入时间和精力去亲自见他们之间的一步。所以视频约会，我的意思是，这真的是对80年代的一种回溯，当时视频约会服务也很受欢迎。在我们有了网络约会之前，人们就在进行视频约会，一种不同类型的视频约会。但我们再次看到了这一点。在大流行期间，平台推出了视频约会功能。我认为这是一个非常积极的步子，朝正确方向迈出的一步。因为当你想到安全问题时，它确实……
let you get to know somebody a little bit better before you meet them. And then it also, it's a way of a meeting that requires a little bit less investment. So you don't have to leave the house. You don't have to go spend money. And so I think for a lot of people, that can be really helpful as a step before meeting in person. Now, when online dating was new back in the early 2000s, there was some stigma around that people were embarrassed to admit that they had. had met online. Does that stigma persist today or has it become so common that people don't mind saying, yeah, yeah, we met each other on an app? So something that's been really surprising to me and pretty interesting is that while this stigma has gone away somewhat, it's also
让你在见到他们之前更好地了解某人。然后它也是一种需要较少投资的见面方式。所以你不必离开家。你不必花钱。因此，我认为对许多人来说，在亲自见面之前，这可以作为一个非常有帮助的步骤。现在，当网络约会在2000年代初还是个新鲜事物时，围绕它有一些耻辱感，人们不好意思承认他们是在网上认识的。这种耻辱感今天仍然存在，还是它已经变得如此普遍，以至于人们不介意说，是的，是的，我们在一个软件上认识的？所以对我来说非常惊讶且相当有趣的一件事是，虽然这种耻辱感在一定程度上已经消失，但它也
become much more platform-specific. So I think online dating has become so common where it's not as stigmatized as it was in, say, the 90s when people were less familiar with it. But now we have these stigmas attached to that actual platform that people are using. And this is something that's come up in my research talking to people who are in long-term relationships that they formed online dating, where I've had people tell me that they don't actually tell everyone in their network. They don't tell, you know, family members how they met because they're afraid that they're going to be judged for the platform they were using. So if they used it, app, they're afraid people will think that they were on there just looking to hook up and looking
变得更加特定于平台。所以我想网络约会已经变得非常普遍，不再像90年代那样受到污名化，当时人们对它不太熟悉。但现在我们有了附着在人们正在使用的实际平台上的这些耻辱感。这是我在与网恋的长期关系中的人交谈的研究中出现的情况，我有人告诉我，他们实际上并没有告诉网络中的所有人。他们没有告诉（你知道的）家庭成员他们是如何认识的，因为他们害怕因为他们使用的平台而被评判。所以如果他们使用了某个软件，他们害怕人们会认为他们去那里只是为了约炮并寻找
for something casual. And so there's that kind of stigma that's coming up for people. And so I was surprised that when we're in an era where online dating is the primary way that people are meeting in the U.S., that there's people that are still making up these cover stories about how they met because they're afraid of the judgment that they're going to receive. And so, yeah, it's gotten better in one way, but it's also changed in another where now it's much more about the app that you were using. You've also studied virtual reality dating.
随意的关系。所以人们会遇到那种耻辱感。因此我很惊讶，当我们处于网络约会是美国人相遇的主要方式的时代时，仍然有人在编造关于他们是如何相遇的掩护故事，因为他们害怕他们将受到的评判。所以，是的，它在一个方面变得更好，但在另一个方面也发生了变化，现在它更多地关乎你使用的软件。你还研究了虚拟现实约会。
What is a virtual reality date? Is this something that people are doing in real life or are they just doing it in research labs right now? Yeah. I mean, right now I think it's primarily in labs, but we also have some startups that are looking at ways that virtual reality can be come a part of the online dating experience. And so when you think of what a virtual reality date might look like, I would visualize an experience that looks a lot more like meeting face-to-face. And this is kind of the irony in all of this,
什么是虚拟现实约会？这是人们在现实生活中做的事情，还是他们现在只在研究实验室里做？是的。我的意思是，现在我认为它主要在实验室里，但我们也有一些初创公司正在寻找虚拟现实如何成为网络约会体验一部分的方法。因此，当你想到虚拟现实约会可能是什么样子时，我会将一种看起来更像面对面的体验可视化。这也是所有这一切中的讽刺之处，
that the more technology advances, the more it takes us back to how we've always dated in person. So instead of swiping through profiles and messaging people, you might walk up to somebody in a virtual bar and maybe buy them a drink or strike up a conversation. And so you're once again meeting people based on proximity, people that are virtually in the same vicinity as you, but you can also benefit from all of the advantages of online dating.
技术进步得越多，它就越把我们带回到我们一贯的面对面约会方式。所以你不用翻阅个人资料和给人们发消息，而是可以走到虚拟酒吧的某个人面前，也许给他们买杯饮料或开始对话。所以你再次根据邻近性结识人，虚拟中与你在同一附近的人，但你也可以受益于网络约会的所有优势。
Like you might still have access to somebody's profile when you're having a conversation with them in this virtual environment. So you get more information. But at the same time, it feels a little bit more organic. And something that I think, is kind of exciting about this idea of using virtual reality and dating is that you're evaluating people based on what it's like to have a conversation with them, which is very different from how we evaluate people on dating apps. So on an app, you're reading a profile, you're
就像当你在这个虚拟环境中与某人交谈时，你可能仍然可以访问某人的个人资料。所以你可以获得更多信息。但与此同时，它感觉更有机一点。我认为使用虚拟现实和约会这个想法令人兴奋的一点是，你是根据与他们交谈的感觉来评估人们的，这与我们在约会软件上评估人们的方式非常不同。所以在软件上，你正在阅读个人资料，你
evaluating them based on that information. But when you have a conversation with somebody, you're paying attention to things like, you know, do they make me laugh? Do I feel like this is a good person? Do I like how they treat me? And, it's just not the same kind of information that you're able to get from a profile. And so I think it could be an exciting direction, but I also think it's a bit of a ways away at this point. So on a VR date, wouldn't you have an avatar and be encountering people's avatar? So you're not even really seeing what they're like, but maybe some idealized idea of what they should be. Yeah. So isn't this kind of false in that sense? I mean, what happens if you meet in real life? And, you know, the person,
根据该信息评估他们。但是当你与某人交谈时，你会注意一些事情，比如（你知道的）他们让我笑吗？我觉得这是一个好人吗？我喜欢他们对待我的方式吗？而且，这与你从个人资料中获得的信息类型不同。所以我认为这可能是一个令人兴奋的方向，但我同时也认为此时它还有一段路要走。所以在VR约会上，难道你不会有一个化身并遇到人们的化身吗？所以你甚至没有真正看到他们是什么样的，而可能是一些关于他们应该是什么样子的某种理想化的想法。是的。所以从这个意义上说，这难道不是有点虚假吗？我的意思是，如果你在现实生活中见面会发生什么？而且，（你知道的）这个人
doesn't resemble their avatar at all. Yeah. And so it's, I mean, that will be a tricky thing about it. When it comes to avatars, it also gives you a lot more control over how you present yourself. I mean, you can really get creative in terms of what you look like. I mean, in terms of your appearance. And so that could lead to more instances of deception and catfishing or at least more concerns about it.
与他们的化身根本不像。是的。所以这是……我的意思是，这将是关于它棘手的事情。当涉及到化身时，它也让你对如何展示自己有更多的控制。我的意思是，在你的外表方面，你可以真正发挥创意。我的意思是，就你的外貌而言。所以这可能会导致更多的欺骗和虚假身份欺诈的实例，或者至少对它的更多担忧。
But again, it's the early days. So we don't really know yet. Now, as we have been saying, dating apps are really popular right now, but there have been a bunch of trend stories lately about how millennials and Jen Ziers are saying that they're sick of them, that they're swearing off online dating, they're deleting their apps. Do you think that the use of dating apps will continue to grow, or are we reaching a point where people are getting burned out and they want to try something different? I think that we are in the burnout era when it comes to dating apps. And when you think about it, we're about 10 years in. Like we're starting to see some long-term outcomes for people who have been on them from the beginning. And some people, you know, they've been on Tinder for the entire time that Tinder has been available
但同样，这是早期阶段。所以我们还不知道。现在，正如我们一直所说的那样，约会软件现在非常受欢迎，但最近有一堆关于千禧一代和Z世代表示他们已经受够了、他们发誓不再进行网络约会、他们正在删除他们的软件的趋势报道。你认为约会软件的使用会继续增长，还是我们正到达一个人们感到筋疲力尽并想尝试不同事物的人点？我认为就约会软件而言，我们正处于倦怠时代。当你仔细想想，我们大约已经进入十年了。就像我们开始看到那些从一开始就使用它们的人的一些长期结果一样。有些人（你知道的），自从Tinder可用以来，他们就一直在Tinder上
and they haven't been able to find what they're looking for. Same goes for some of the other apps where people at this point have been on there from the beginning and they're getting fed up because they're not able to find whatever drew them to the apps in the first place. And so, I mean, I think it's hard to imagine a future where technology suddenly becomes disconnected from how we date. And I think some of it is people potentially romanticizing a time when dating apps didn't exist. I mean, when you look at especially Gen Z, they have grown up in an environment where dating apps, social media, have always been available to them. So the idea of just meeting somebody face to face without the help of technology, I mean, that hasn't been a reality for a lot of people because it's always been a way that they've
而且他们一直无法找到他们正在寻找的东西。其他一些软件也是如此，此时人们从一开始就一直在那里，他们感到厌烦，因为他们无法找到最初吸引他们使用软件的东西。因此，我的意思是，很难想象未来技术会突然与我们的约会方式脱节。我认为其中一部分可能是人们将没有约会软件的时代浪漫化了。我的意思是，当你审视特别是Z世代时，他们在一个约会软件和社交媒体随时可用的环境中长大。因此，仅仅在没有技术帮助的情况下结识某人的想法，我的意思是，这对许多人来说并不是现实，因为它一直是他们能够建立关系的一种方式。
been able to form relationships. And so I think some people are kind of nostalgic for that a little bit. And I also think they're frustrated with the dating app experience. I do think that there is change on the horizon when it comes to online dating. and especially when I look at AI and how that might start to play a role in this landscape, I think that, you know, we're at a really pivotal moment with online dating. At the same time, I don't think it's going to go away. I could see it transforming in the next couple of years, especially because of advances in AI.
所以我认为有些人对此有点怀旧。我也认为他们对约会软件的体验感到沮丧。我确实认为网络约会的未来即将发生变化，特别是当我看到人工智能以及它如何开始在这个领域发挥作用时，我认为（你知道的）我们正处于网络约会的关键时刻。与此同时，我不认为它会消失。我可以看到它在接下来的几年里发生转型，特别是因为人工智能的进步。
In what ways? What do you envision? Will we all just create AI dates and, you know, they'll be the people we want and love and we can just make them, what we want them to be and fall in love with them and live with them forever. Yeah. I mean, what I'm hoping that future looks like is one where people are relying more on AI for facilitating relationships and less,
在哪些方面？你设想什么？我们都会创造人工智能约会对象，（你知道的）他们将是我们想要和爱的人，我们可以把他们做成我们想让他们成为的样子，并与他们坠入爱河并永远和他们生活在一起。是的。我的意思是，我希望未来的样子是人们更多地依靠人工智能来促进关系，而更少地……
less for actually being the relationship partner that they're looking for. But people are already like using chat GPT to help them come up with opening lines to help them create their profiles. So they're already relying on AI as almost a date coach. someone, something to help them be a little bit better in the dating environment. That's a cheat. That's a big cheat. At opening line, you need AI to tell you how to do that.
更少地将其作为他们正在寻找的实际恋爱伴侣。但人们已经在使用ChatGPT来帮助他们想出开场白，帮助他们创建个人资料。所以他们已经将人工智能用作几乎是约会教练的角色。某人、某物，可以帮助他们在约会环境中表现得更好一点。这是作弊。这是一个大作弊。在开场白上，你需要人工智能来告诉你怎么做。
Yeah. And then you think about, okay, so then what happens when you get off the app, right? If you start using AI to help you write all of your messages, eventually you're going to get to the point where you can't use it anymore and you might come across as being very different compared to how you portrayed yourself on the app. So I think apps are going to have to figure out exactly how much they want to allow people to rely people to rely on AI. And so I think that's one way that it might play a role. And then there's also startups that are experimenting with ways to use AI in matchmaking.
是的。然后你会想，好吧，那么当你离开软件时会发生什么，对吧？如果你开始使用人工智能来帮你写所有的消息，最终你会到达一个你不能再使用它的点，与你在软件上描绘自己相比，你给人的印象可能会非常不同。所以我认为软件将不得不弄清楚他们究竟想让人们在多大程度上依赖人工智能。所以我认为这是它可能发挥作用的一种方式。然后还有一些初创公司正在尝试在 matchmaking 中使用人工智能的方法。
And a lot of apps are doing this actually. But some of their ideas, they get pretty creative. I mean, some are talking about having people train AI to represent them and to go on dates for them. So instead of having to swipe on your own, you've now taught an AI to go out and interact on your behalf and to come back with some partners he might be interested in. So, I mean, there's so many different ways that I think these platforms are looking at incorporating AI and the experience. And I mean, I think it's hard to imagine that this isn't going to play a big role. It's just a matter of figuring out exactly what is the best way to utilize this. to make online dating better for people.
其实很多应用程序都在这样做。但它们的一些想法非常富有创意。我的意思是，有些人谈论让人们训练人工智能来代表自己，并替自己去约会。因此，你不再需要自己去滑动匹配，而是教会了一个人工智能代表你出去互动，并带回它可能感兴趣的伴侣。所以，我的意思是，我认为这些平台在将人工智能融入体验方面有如此多的不同方式。我的意思是，很难想象这不会发挥重要作用。这只是一个弄清楚利用这一点的最佳方式是什么的问题，从而让人们的在线约会变得更好。
What got you interested in this line of research? Yeah. I mean, I'm really, really intrigued by the potential of using technology to help people find love and to really help people make better decisions when it comes to their choice of a romantic partner. I think there's so much potential here. And at the same time, I also think that some people do have. have really negative experiences when they use technology for dating. It can be really frustrating for a lot of people. And so I think there's a lot of room for improvement. But I'm really excited
是什么让你对这个研究方向感兴趣？是的。我的意思是，我真的对利用技术帮助人们寻找真爱以及真正帮助人们在选择浪漫伴侣时做出更好决策的潜力非常感兴趣。我认为这里有巨大的潜力。与此同时，我也认为有些人确实有。在使用交友软件时有非常负面的体验。对许多人来说，这可能真的很令人沮丧。所以我认为还有很大的改进空间。但我真的感到很兴奋
about the possibility of how we might use technology to help people facilitate better connections and to have happier relationships. So what are you working on now? What are your big research projects on the horizon? Yeah. So one study that I'm working on currently is looking at dating at burnout, the experience of burnout over time, who's most susceptible to it? Because I think we are at that point where people are feeling frustrated. And so trying to figure out, okay, why is this experience not working for some people? Why are some people not successful in finding what they're looking for? Because I've also been looking at long-term relationships that come out of online dating and people's success stories. And, you know, they have such different
关于如何利用技术帮助人们促进更好的连接并拥有更幸福的关系的可能性。那么你现在在做什么？你接下来的重大研究项目是什么？是的。我目前正在进行的一项研究是关于约会倦怠，即随着时间的推移倦怠的体验，谁最容易受到它的影响？因为我认为我们正处于这样一个阶段，人们感到沮丧。因此，试图弄清楚，为什么这种体验对某些人不起作用？为什么有些人无法成功找到他们想要的东西？因为我也一直在研究在线交友带来的长期关系以及人们的成功故事。而且，你知道，他们有如此不同的
experiences where some people meet the love of their life. I mean, it changes their life. The fact that they used online dating and they found someone they wouldn't otherwise meet. And then for other people, they've been on the apps for years and they've spent so much time and money and gotten nowhere. And so trying to figure out exactly what makes some people successful in the apps while others really struggle. Well, Dr. Sharabi, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting. Thanks a lot. Thank you for having me on. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.combeingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a
体验，有些人遇到了他们一生的挚爱。我的意思是，这改变了他们的生活。他们使用了在线交友并且找到了他们否则无法遇到的人这一事实。而对于另一些人来说，他们在应用程序上待了多年，花费了大量的时间和金钱却一无所获。因此，试图弄清楚究竟是什么让一些人在应用程序上获得成功，而另一些人却苦苦挣扎。好吧，沙拉比博士，我要感谢你今天加入我的节目。这真的非常有趣。非常感谢。谢谢你邀请我。您可以在我们的网站 www.apa.org/news/podcasts/speaking-of-psychology 上或在 Apple、Stitcher、YouTube 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》以前的节目。如果您喜欢我们节目的内容，请订阅并给我们留下
review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学对话》由莉·温纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的音响编辑是克里斯·孔迪恩（Chris Condyenne）。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。